jean-vincent placé le toujours président
du groupe écologiste au sénat est
l'invité de presse par trois bonsoir je
dis toujours voulait que depuis quelques
mois mais vous n'êtes pas devenu janvier
une ministre à 1
voilà une ambition contrariée vous en
parlerai tout à l'heure avec perrine
tarneaud c'est pour tout à l'heure dans
la dernière partie de cette émission
avec perrine de public sénat avant est
le sujet de blocs de l' agence
france-presse notre partenaire vous
interrogera sur l'enjeu des législatives
pour les écologistes les téléspectateurs
notez-le peuvent intervenir durant cette
émission ils peuvent poser leurs
questions à travers l'application tivi
tchèque d'orange
d'abord jean vincent placé votre
réaction à l'examen par la cour de
cassation de la validité des
condamnations dont celles de total pour
la marée noire de l'erika je rappelle
c'était en 1999 400 km de côtes
souillées cent cinquante mille oiseaux
mazoutés
la décision sera rendue le 25 septembre
mais l'avocat général recommande bien
l'annulation de ces condamnation pour
vice de forme prise de procédure
les scouts et se trouve ça scandaleux
concernant catastrophique pour la cause
écologique déjà treize ans après on se
retrouve dans une telle situation ou en
cassation ont dit que il faut annuler la
procédure alors qu'on voit les dégâts
terribles qui ont été faits sur ses
côtes sur le plan évidemment écologique
mais aussi économique et social et que
on annulerait tous ainsi parce que il y
aurait des incompatibilités ou des
contradictions entre les différentes
conventions internationales respect des
droits maritimes riz mais on peut
toujours tout regarder à la loupe de
façon y compris méticuleuse et je ne
remets pas en cause particulièrement le
travail des juristes en la matière mais
tout de même les temps ont changé il
faut aussi tenir compte des réalités là
ça devient vraiment mais je suis accablé
et j'espère quand même parce que la
décision n'a lieu que à l'automne vous
l'avez indiqué qui pourra y avoir une
prise en compte aujourd'hui de
l'allemand sont sinon dans politique du
moins dans l'urgence écologique sur
cette question leurs voeux c'est donc
une lecture révoltante et abstraite du
droit
au sol et quand je n'ai pas d'exemple en
tête mais quand on voit quelque chose de
totalement aberrant une des règles
anciennes parce que je crois cette
fameuse convention internationale a été
faite en 82 mise mise en place en
réalité en 96
peut-être même d'ailleurs avant la
question écologique de façon aussi
affirmé au niveau planétaire
eh bien il faut tenir compte des
réalités en dehors de deux des
différentes zones dans cette zone
internationale parce que ta vie on
maltais on serait absous de toute
responsabilité
parce que le pays en question malte
n'aurait pas attaquer ne devrait pas
seraient pas portés à demander préjudice
parce que c'est de cela dont il s'agit
sur le plan du droit
enfin que même toi et c'est aberrant le
droit ne doit pas être à l'heure de
doivent ne doit pas être révoltant le
droit doit correspondre juste à de la
justice ce n'est pas le cas alors
peut-être que c'est un sujet d'union
nationale on en cherche de temps à autre
dans notre pays
pas pendant les périodes électorales
évidemment j'aurais sans placer mais
votre collègue bruno retailleau qui est
par ailleurs président du conseil
général de vendée annonce une
proposition de loi pour sanctionner tout
préjudice écologique là vous le suivez
oui on l'avait pas attendu d'ailleurs en
besoin et déjà différentes dispositions
qui sont mises en place depuis 2004
notamment sur le sujet mais bien sûr
tout tout élément qui va dans ce sens là
est le bienvenu et sinon union nationale
la mobilisation des consciences et des
volontés et bien c'est très bien mais
alors vous n'avez pas mis en cause je
vous l'avais dit il ya un instant
l'avocat général remettait pas en cause
de magique mais je me souviens pendant
la campagne présidentielle eva joly elle
l avait dénoncé une complicité entre
l'état et total
alors là elle parle et je ne pense pas
de l'avocat général en l'occurrence mais
en revanche dans toute la période qui a
eu lieu avant la cassation et au moment
de l'appel et on a eu quand même et les
collectivités locales qui avait attaqué
en particulier la région pays de la
loire le département de la vendée de
même avait eu des interrogations très
très forte dans la cadre de
la volonté d'obtenir un compromis
notamment avec total et des services
disons de l'ue ministère des finances
donc moi je n'incrimine personne mais il
y avait quand même de grandes
interrogations quant à savoir si on
voulait faire prévaloir la justice ou si
on voulait protéger une entreprise
nationale qui bien évidemment est
importante à des parlant du gouvernement
héros avec deux écologistes glauque
cécile duflot et parce qu'elle
commencerait ce que vous vous êtes
totalement heureux mais en plus je sais
que en ce moment je me fais taquiner là
dessus mais moi je suis très à l'aise
parce que j'affiche tout à la fois des
ambitions parce que je j'assume j'assume
mais les ambitions
après je suis très heureux des
présidents du groupe existe au sénat et
en plus je vais vous dire pourquoi je ne
suis pas déçu parce que je trouve ce
gouvernement au delà même de cécile
duflot et de pascal canfin qui sont des
gens remarquables qui ont une bonne
image qui sont des gens compétents et
sérieux avec des ministères très
intéressant je trouve que françois
hollande et jean marc ayrault ont réussi
à confectionner un gouvernement
extrêmement équilibrée paritaire ce qui
est extrêmement positif est évidemment
une nouveau équilibré sur le plan des
territoires équilibré sur le plan des
générations et avec des origines de
compétences de façons très diverses et
je trouve ça très positif donc c'est un
beau bébé d origine tout court arrivé au
oui c'est les l'oublier parce que moi
intérieur il me pousse à peut-être avant
mais c'est un beau gouvernement de la
gauche diverse qui qui est là et qui je
pense de non vie aux françaises et aux
français pour ces élections législatives
de renforcer la majorité présidentielle
dans sa diversité bien évidemment car
vous le savez nous avons beaucoup de
candidats écolos et il faut de la
diversité dans cette majorité
présidentielle dans cette majorité à
laquelle vous appartenez de votre
présence à ce gouvernement n'en parlera
dans un restaurant avec ce que tu vas
suzette qui est avec nous est ce que
l'écologie sera bien défendu et
représenté par nicole bricq et avec qui
vous avez eu le temps de faire
connaissance au sénat oui il y avait il
ya deux sujets donc déjà le sujet du
périmètre du ministère de l'écologie
nous étions et je l'avais dit avant la
formation du gouvernement
très attentif à au périmètre à la force
du ministère de l'écologie je l'avais
dit si tu étais fâcheuse serait fâcheux
que
après le gouvernement où on avait prévu
que monsieur juppé et puis monsieur
borloo puis madame kosciusko morizet
d'un gouvernement où il y à un grand
ministère de l'écologie même si je le
fais institutionnels ne suffit pas pour
faire une bonne politique écologique
comme l'ont démontré
alors là vous étiez bien c'était
important le résultat compris le débat
qui suscite évidemment aussi controverse
par rapport aux écologistes sur le
périmètre incluant l'énergie
eh bien nous sommes satisfaits que le
ministère de l'écologie et de la
cohésion et de la puissance et se crée
donc réellement de l'énergie pour sur le
sujet le maire éric pourrait également
complètement votre question moi je la
connaissais déjà en tant qu'élu régional
francilien parce qu'elle est de dessiner
marne et j'ai découverte à la commission
des finances bon vraiment de très grande
qualité femme de dossiers de compétence
économique fiscale et je pense c'est
l'engagement son engagement chez les ja
c'est à dire que sur les gaz de schiste
à l'exemple elle après le combat auprès
de nos élus écologistes de
seine-et-marne en particulier madame les
pièces qui est la suivante de liste sur
la liste sénatoriale remplacer et
demande à mme bricq tout à la fois pour
moi une femme compétente intéressé aux
questions écologiques et en plus comme
c'est une spécialiste des questions
fiscales j'y vois un énorme intérêt
notamment par rapport à la mise en place
de la taxe carbone la fameuse
contribution énergie climat et de
l'ensemble des mesures fiscales qui
peuvent être forte dans le domaine c'est
important tout à la fois la régulation
et la fiscalité dans le domaine la
régulation écologique vient de se
souvenir que nicole bricq a mené le
combat contre les gaz de schiste mais
vous parlez pas du nucléaire on la
connaît pas anti nucléaires n'ont pas
fait ça vous gêne ou pas vous sert les
jeunes bougeait nous personne ne vous a
pas échappé que le président la
république a été élu il a été élu sur un
programme et ce programme d'ailleurs
correspond au compromis que nous avons
créés dans l'accord ps
ryanair le jir maintenant maintenant
mais c'est si vous permettez de faire
des réponses et
vous pouvez tout faire mais moi j'ai
servi en défense et bien l'orientation
du président la république que nous
partageons sur l'accord de compromis
c'est 75% à 50% d'ici 2025 de la
production d'électricité en france par
le nucléaire
bien sûr nous nous fermons fessenheim
maintenant et nous voulons qu'il y ait
plus de réacteurs qui soit fermé et plus
vite
oui ça ne vous a pas échappé que nous
n'avons pas le rapport de force d'accord
les conditions pour cela traduit le sens
du compromis
je pense que madame bric se rattacher à
ce compromis 75 50 % au développement
des énergies renouvelables qui l'autre
élément de cet accord qui est
extrêmement important ray sur le
photovoltaïque sur le solaire sur les
éoliennes sont intervenus également sur
le troisième sujet effectivement c'est
la question de la maîtrise justement de
la consommation énergétique qui est un
gros volet notamment sur le bâtiment et
le logement et nous irions ou madame
duflot
voilà un site duflot ministre de
l'égalité des territoires et du logement
et ce volet-là sera un volet très
important en lien avec madame michu qui
elle s'occupe de la réforme de l'état
donc vous voyez tout ça
selon la collégialité et la
transversalité pourrait faire une belle
politique écologique d'accord très bien
vous avez dire on ferme fessenheim tout
de suite non quand même pas tout de
suite dans cinq ans à la fin du
quinquennat c'est ce qu'a dit le
candidat quand on nourrit nan gang et ça
c'est intéressant quand on entame la
décision de fermer ça se fait sur quatre
sur la durance à ce que ce qui est
montré son la république et c'est ça la
réalité maintenant toute famille que
nous avions parlé de madame duflot
cécile duflot ministre jusqu'à présent
c'est lui reprocher son jim lors du
premier niveau ling ridicule mais l'ump
a trouvé d'autres têtes de turc est
ailleurs avec arnaud montebourg
finalement un peu je suis réseau
confrères de journalisme dans les
familles de travail une fois un journal
de 20 heures et il avait reçues
paraît-il plein de lettres et tout ça
enfin voir franchement c'est parce que
non non cravate que tout le monde oublie
le d'arnaud montebourg
condamné pour insulte et puis christiane
taubira alors l'a accusée de laxisme
mais qu'est ce que vous avez envie de
dire pour les défendre l'un et l'autre
ben c'est ce que je vous dise enfin des
personnes j'espère non visage d'enlever
un ministre de la république parce qu'il
aurait eu un propos peut-être un peu
excessif qu'il a regretté aujourd'hui
s'il est bien un prix jure la
diffamation c'est pas bien enfin voila
c'est parfois y compris dans dans le
champ politique
voilà ça fait partie des choses ils ont
les chaussées les questions tant que
c'est pas atteinte à l'honneur ou la
dignité des uns et des autres et que ça
reste sur le coup c'est beaucoup plus
plus grave parce que je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la droite est dans une
nasse dans la défaite
elle essaye de se ressaisir que non pas
sur des propositions pour le pays mais
sur des mots d'ordre et comprit très
ciblées individuellement
et quand on dit quand on dit quand même
ce score que à un haut responsable de
l'ump qui par haïti les républicains qui
dit voter front national c'est à voir
madame taubira comprenez qu'on arrive
quand même à faire des raccourcis comme
extrêmement fâché les propositions qui
sont faites sur la suppression du
tribunal de correctionnel pour les
mineurs délinquants c'est dans les
propositions du président la république
donc c'est pas madame taubira
particulièrement c'est monsieur hollande
c'est le chef du gouvernement également
donc il faut interpeller donc c'est un
débat politique d'ailleurs on est pour
ou on est contre donc voilà il faut
mettre tout sur la table
ensuite inventé des fausses déclarations
sur le fait qu' alors été contente qu'on
connaîtra poterie corps je ne sais quoi
enfin où en sommes-nous à moi et pour ma
part je connais très très bien fait sial
de tombes ira depuis assez longtemps
d'ailleurs c'est une femme d'honneur de
dignité de compétences de responsabilité
très attaché à la république
particulièrement la laïcité et c'est
vraiment je trouve un procès à nominem
si j'ose dire scandaleux alors voter ps
et vous aurez le front national et opéra
c'est une phrase de jean françois copé
qui est engagé aujourd'hui dans une
guerre des chefs avec françois fillon
oui à quoi les bisbilles ne sont pas
réservées aux écologistes
aujourd'hui parce que dès qu'il ya une
idée installer c'est que on disait dans
le temps les écologistes ils sont
bordéliques allez disons un gros mot à
cette heure-ci
et puis ils sont divisés aujourd'hui sur
lui et aujourd'hui ils sont divisés
j'irais pas jusqu'a à redire ce mot
trivial déjà utilisé mais ils sont très
divisés oui mais par ailleurs mon nom je
suis parlementaire à faire je me réjouis
pas parce que je pense que la qualité du
débat démocratique c'est de faire des
propositions c'est c'est parler des
grands enjeux ils feraient mieux de
parler de ce qui s'est passé à l'otan de
désengagement de nos troupes en
afghanistan une promesse que le
président hollande tient de la fermeté
de la discussion avec les allemands et
l'union européenne sur la question d'une
renégociation du traité sur la volonté
de faire des eurobunds pour investir
davantage dans des industries nouvelles
enfin bon voilà donc parlons de projets
gouvernementaux de l'encadrement des
loyers par madame duflot du fait que sur
les hébergements d'urgence
on fait attention y compris des risques
au 31 mai enfin bon j'ai reçu j'ai fort
par le gouvernement a déjà déjà quand on
est un soutien du gouvernement comme moi
c'est bien naturel de
de le défendre allez on va en parler
juste pendant un instant annoncé que
l'enjeu politique du moment c'est bien
sûr le scrutin législatif avec des coups
de cannes nice à l'accord entre le ps et
europe ecologie les verts des dissidents
partent donc à l'assaut de
circonscription qui vous étaient
réservées comme comme on dit par exemple
à lyon une bataille fait rage dans la
première circonscription entre deux
belles têtes d'affiché comme l'a
constaté françois gaulin le candidat
investi par le ps s'est lui l'écologiste
philippe meirieu l'accord signé entre
les verts et le parti socialiste l'a
officiellement désigné il y a 6 mois
mais à quelques rues de là dans la même
circonscription le dissident radical
thierry braillard mène également content
je suis candidat ici aux élections
législatives pour françois hollande
gérard collomb les tracts de ses deux
concurrents de gauche se ressemblent
étrangement l'un affiche la rose
socialiste l'autre est la copie conforme
du dépliant de françois hollande pendant
la dernière campagne
tous deux affichent d'ailleurs le
soutien du président mais que se
passe-t-il à solférino le parti
socialiste me fait savoir par
l'intermédiaire de christophe borgel que
je suis le candidat officiel du parti
socialiste
ça ne m'empêche pas de me retrouver sur
les marchés avec des gens qui
distribuent pour mon concurrent du
premier tour avec les drapeaux du parti
socialiste et c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué au quotidien tiré braillard
lui ce sont légitimes
pour preuve il s'est installé dans les
anciens locaux du ps
alors monsieur braillard êtes vous un
dissident absolument pas j'étais investi
à l'unanimité par les instances
nationales de mon parti le parti radical
de gauche
je pense en tout cas avoir toute
légitimité a mené campagne dans cette
circonscription avec notamment le
soutien de gérard collomb qui n'est pas
à lyon à main soutient les candidats
socialistes qui se présente malgré
l'accord avec les verts sont normalement
exclues du parti le maire de lyon se
moque de ces menaces
il considère depuis des mois que cet
accord électoral est une aberration le
candidat qu on nous imposait était
quelqu'un qui a la région vote contre
tous les dossiers importants pour
l'agglomération à lyonnais
dossiers économiques dossier culturel
arc évidemment pour le maire de lyon ce
n'est pas possible de soutenir de telles
candidatures au siège du ps à paris on
assure qu'il n'y a qu'un candidat et que
thierry braillard usurpe eu le soutien
du président hollande
c'est dans ce joyeux bazar que les
électeurs devront faire leur choix
voilà joyeux bazar on va pas reprendre
le mot utilisé ces sept blocs de l'
agence france-presse
notre partenaire est avec nous qu'on
soir s'il est bon cela en question aussi
majeure que répondez-vous à monsieur
collomb on cite un de vos collègues au
sein de la majorité au sénat pour rien
monsieur collomb je dis juste aux
électrices et aux électeurs de la
première circonscription du rhône donc à
lyon qu'il y a un candidat un seul qui
est soutenu par le parti socialiste et
europe écologie les verts
les candidats du rassemblement de la
gauche et des écologistes et qui est
soutenu par françois hollande la part
françois hollande chacun fait ce qu'il
veut aussi on a peut-être des procédures
et des choses comme ça moi je parle du
candidat qui s'appelle fille peyrieu qui
est vice-président de la région
rhône-alpes qui est un homme formidable
qui professeur d'université un grand
spécialiste des questions d'éducation et
et des sciences de l'éducation
d'éducation populaire et voilà très
simplement il faut à un moment qu'on
voit effectivement on en a pas une mais
ce grossiord qu'on voit ce qui se passe
à droite
les divisions des dissensions individuel
les luttes d'ambition il faut pas donner
cette image là et donc le candidat de la
gauche et des écologistes en selle
circonscription la première du rhône
c'est philippe meirieu et j'invite tous
nos cd spectateurs à voter pour lui le
18 mois prochain en ligne c'est aussi
parce qu'il n'ya pas que la première
circonscription mais non il ya aussi
bien d'autres circonscriptions plus près
d'une quinzaine
est ce que vous ne pensez pas que trop
dissidente eu l'accord que vous avez
passé avec martine aubry
non parce que
vous savez il ya toujours des rappeurs
des dissidents mais qui seront des
candidats bon qui par ailleurs ont bien
le droit peut-être de compte de se dire
qu'ils pourraient être candidats de
façon autonome
moi je vois notamment que face à madame
royal il ya le premier secrétaire
fédéral de charente maritime du parti
socialiste qui est candidat mais ça je
sais pas pourquoi on en parle moins
contre différents responsables du parti
socialiste olivier ferrand qui n'est pas
n'importe qui dans la huitième des
bouches du rhône il ya un maire local du
parti socialiste et bien il y a des des
élus locaux dans les circonscriptions
concernées qui ne sont pas satisfaits
arbitrage
moi je peux le comprendre je me souviens
en 2007 j'avais été dans un accord puis
cet accord ne s'était pas passé ben
voilà qui j'avais tiré les leçons en
ayant une certaine forme de discipline à
discipline ça veut pas dire l'obéissance
et épi des aveugles ça veut dire aussi
qu'on pense que l'intérêt général
l'intérêt général de la gauche et les
écologistes
l'intérêt général pour le coût de la
politique on veut mener pour la france
parce qu'il nous faut une majorité
parlementaire
donc moi j'en appelle à la
responsabilité des uns et les autres
choses que vous ne pourrez pas réparé
aussi le faible score le ni-ni score
d'une eva joly à la présidentielle
moi je dis d'ailleurs à l'ensemble des
observateurs des journalistes des
citoyens peut simplement il ya une
mobilisation en france sur l'élection de
présidentielle lundi l'élection
présidentielle elle est faite pour élire
un président il est élu ce présent et
j'en suis très content j'ai voté pour
lui au deuxième tour
maintenant il faut passer à autre chose
vous voulez que nous soyons comme sous
nicolas sarkozy ou le président il est
là il désigne les gens qui vont être
député il son doigt sur la couture du
pantalon on a vu ce que ça donnait au
sénat sont tellement suivi aveuglément
tout ce que raconte et ne se sarkozy que
même les grands électeurs qui quand même
sont pas forcément instinctivement de la
gauche et des écologistes et bien
rejeter cette majorité
eh bien il nous faut une république
comme le dit d'ailleurs le président la
république françois hollande est une
république équilibrée décentralisée et
contractualisés voilà ce qu'il faut et
c'est pour ça qu'au moment des élections
législatives moi je le fais un appel
très amicale mais quand même solennel
aux électrices et électeurs qui ont voté
utile autour de françois hollande pour
dire qu'il faut tout à la fois une
majorité derrière françois hollande
une majorité plus équilibrée et c'est
pour ça j'ai invite tout le monde à
voter et que
c'est par exemple pour philippe meirieu
donc dans cette belle invention ya la
réalité donc de tous ces dissidences une
ambition c'est combien de députés
nous l'avons dit nous voulons un groupe
parlementaire et il me semble que
légitimement nous pourrions être à
hauteur de 18 20 députés nesquik
incroyable j'ai visité auparavant ce
pari d'une trentaine jamais d'une
trentaine j'avais dit 22 23 et
effectivement les dissidents sont
peut-être nous coûter 3 4 ch quand vous
voyez moi je vous dis des choses très
très réellement mais est ce que je veux
dire aussi c'est que personne y compris
d'ailleurs les rohff en gauche on est
quand même dans un dans un pays on
serait surpris faisant député
chronologie sur 577
on ferait même que sur le ratio sur 3 %
ça nous donnerait 18 députés sont et à
la proportionnelle nous les premiers
sondages qui sortent les statines nous
met déjà quatre et demi à 5 et 6 étaient
à proportionnelle serait 25 30 et on a
tous intériorisé la vème république qui
fait qu' on trouve normal que le parti
socialiste ou d'ailleurs avant l'ump
avec 27 28 % des voix vont avoir
peut-être 50 à 60 % des sièges
mais qu'est ce que tu es ce que c'est
cette démocratie il n'y aurait que des
députés socialistes même temps qu'il
soutiendrait tout ce que dit françois
hollande
moi je suis globalement dans ce que dit
françois hollande sinon j'aurais pas
voté pour lui mais je pense quand même
que pendant cinq ans quand on voit
l'actrice qu'on voit les évolutions
qu'on voit les nouvelles les nouvelles
situations et bien c est important
d'avoir des discussions la majorité on
aura bien plus de discussion s'il n'y a
pas que quand même j'espère
essentialiste et russes de discussions
mais jean vincent placé vous avez appris
il ya un instant les électeurs qui vous
écoute a envoyé une majorité rg ce faire
il faut bien manger équilibré et vous
dit à l'assemblée nationale ça veut dire
que vous appeler les électeurs à ne pas
envoyer une majorité absolue
le député socialiste vous parle je ne
suis pas en négatif et j'ai rien à mes
parti socialiste voulait composer une
majorité relative à la pièce vous a posé
les jalons aussi là pour celui-ci je
vais vous donner un avis au journal le
soir j'étais dans une réunion
amicale où il y avait une dizaine de
personnes tôt et dont la très grande
majorité avait voté pour françois
hollande et moi je suis m'ont dit on à
voter pour françois hollande pour être
utile pour le faire gagner
mais aux élections est hâtive on va
revenir sur le vote écologiste et je
crois que c'est très important par
rapport à l'ensemble des enjeux dont on
n'a pas assez parlé
le dérèglement climatique les questions
de pénétrer les ressources naturelles
ta question du pétrolier sont l'énergie
ce très bon et je m'en suis tout à fait
satisfait mais ce n'est pas un problème
des mini c'est un prêt de la majorité
parlementaire
moi je souhaite qu'on est une république
qui aie veulent plus chers vers sixième
république s'est pas encore à l'ordre du
jour etc ou le parlement retrouve son
rôle tout à la fois d'ailleurs
l'assemblée nationale décentralisation
non me faire dire qu'avec les
socialistes soient forts moi je souhaite
que les socialistes soient forts et
parce que les écologistes soient forts
parce que il faut qu'il y ait un
équilibre dans la majorité
et quelque part aussi je suis aussi
attentifs à ce que le front de gauche
parti communiste français également est
une réalité par le bayern autres rapts
et quand même puisqu'il eut pas trouvé
de rappel pour vous pour la dissidence
mais vous allez dire pourquoi des
dissidents il faudrait peut-être prendre
des dispositions voulait dire des
sanctions non mais ça le parti
socialiste n'a comment ça fait
d'ailleurs martine aubry et françois
hollande présent république on dit que
l'accord serait respecté pour ma part je
considère qu'il est respecté on n'est
pas dans la police politique s'il ya des
gens qui votent candidate est candidate
mais en revanche ils ne peuvent pas se
prévaloir du soutien du parti socialiste
et encore moins du président la
république parce que présent république
a indiqué que dans ses 63
circonscription il considérait que celui
qui use celle qui le représentait était
le candidat d'europe écologie les verts
ça c'est très adroit dans ses autres
ratés quand même c'est l'échec de
l'accord de lagos pour une candidature
unique en cas de front national très
fort alors à qui la faute à votre avis à
jean luc mélenchon il
vous avez raison là pour le coup donc là
c'est un premier premières acrobaties
d'accord il ne s'est pas de l'autre
accroc ça c'est un non mais c'est pas en
sourdine répond je pense que en tant que
responsable de la gauche c'est pas bien
pour moi trans tâter cet échec qui était
règles et que je reprenais imputable à
je pense que nos amis notamment du parti
de gauche ont été coincés dans leur
stratégie tout à la fois des trêves et
montrer révolutionnaire traits parfois
même emphatiquement est tout à la fois
avoir le souci légitime d'avoir une
représentation au niveau parlementaire
et avec le scrutin uninominal il vaut
mieux effectivement faire désaccord
alors on n'a pas pu aboutir je pense
qu'a eue la surenchère on l'a dit de
lapin du parti de gauche de jean luc
mélenchon bon voilà je ne veux pas en
faire une affaire parce que le sujet par
rapport au national est extrêmement
important et il faut qu'on soit très
très clairs au premier tour bien sûr et
puis au 2e tour aussi donc ça s'est
infligé comme sérieux au-delà de la
crise passée la forêt littorale qui le
fait que jean luc mélenchon se serait
présenté à hénin beaumont n'a pas
irriter fortement le ps non je crois que
son candidat
je pense pas qu'il y ait une volonté de
preuve plutôt interrogé par socialiste
mais je pense pas qu'à une volonté de
rétorsion je crois que c'est pas du tout
l'état disque du moment mais c'est vrai
que de monter comme ça le débat en
disant il ya avis front national à
hénin-beaumont en vérité il n'y a pas de
risques pré nationale françois
d'entreprise et 60 % au deuxième tour il
y a
peut-être c'était une subvention
socialiste dernière en réalité et nous
mais nous avions proposé à jean luc
mélenchon d'aller plutôt dans un vrai
risque front national dans une
circonscription d'ailleurs qui est dans
l'accord à europe ecologie les verts
notamment à gardanne on allait proposer
c'est ton ancienne circonscription
communiste à jean luc mélenchon
il a préféré la hénin beaumont bon on
verra les résultats mais quelque part je
trouve que le côté publicitaire
marketing de la démarche même si
évidemment il son combat sur le fond
toutes les thèses extrémistes du front
national fait que madame le pen est
encore plus mise en avant dans ce débat
là est très sincèrement je ne me réjouis
pas qu encore pendant trois semaines on
voit autant madame le pen défendent ces
thèses toujours et d'exclusion et de
division du pays a pris c'est is your et
qu'il puisse décoller au gouvernement
aux ordres de poser la question et sans
vous je vois qu'on s'était beaucoup à
ces questions mais il faudrait poser la
question présent république et au
premier ministre
moi je vais vous dire et je les dirige
une grosse heure c'est un gouvernement
très équilibré alors soit le front de
gauche et ça c'est plus politique rentre
dans ce gouvernement ce que moi je
souhaite parce que j'ai toujours été
attaché tout à la fois à la cohérence à
et à une volonté commune met à la
diversité et à la diversité joignant ce
n'est pas un mais et ça c'est le pari
est bien plus important que tout autre
remaniement en sachant que rempli je
vais être très franc avec vous je pense
qu'il vaut mieux pas trop romagné parce
que les ministres commencent à
travailler sans a pas beaucoup de sens
où claude à moi de changer à tout bout
de champ des extraits de venir eva joly
elle souhaitait en commission au
commissariat qu'on dit il en est on
c'est le même débat que pour le
gouvernement
cc duflot à l'égalité des territoires et
au logement je crois qu'elle connaît
très très bien ces sujets étaient très
capable parce qu'un confort c'est
quelqu'un qui connaît très bien les
questions de régulation financière
économique et pour le court en matière
de développement ça me parle importants
y compris en termes de rupture par
rapport à ce qui se faisait avant la
coopération et à gand françafrique
ah oui à des gens et le changement c'est
m sémantique plomb france afrique
oui bien sûr je pense à une volonté du
président république de changer la
dénomination du de ce portefeuille
ministériel et
eva joly on le sait a des grandes
compétences en matière de lutte contre
les paradis fiscaux obtenue de contre la
corruption sur l'éthique financière et
donc bien sûr est né à israël mais elle
met à disposition du gouvernement et du
chef de l'état ses grandes compétences
et j'espère sera un écho assez
rapidement parce que je pense que sur
ces dossiers là il ya une fente
d'urgence merci beaucoup souhaitent
d'abord est avec nous ce soir
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de
l'importance des eurobonds ce qu'il
faudrait relancer lancé en europe et
c'est le temps de faire françois
hollande mais en gala merkel lui réponds
ça n'a aucun sens de tout ramener aux
rebonds
comment est-ce que vous jugez le nouveau
bras de fer ou le nouveau rapport de
force de négociation qui se fait sur des
positions vous l'indiquez différentes
sans caricaturer on pourrait dire de
droite et de gauche dans une très tourné
quand même peut-être même plus loin
encore que la rigueur vers une certaine
forme d'austérité
on a le président un public qui a
développé ses analyses
pendant la campagne électorale ils ont
les honneurs franco allemand est bien le
moteur franco-allemand à dire le moteur
le moteur franco allemand s'était pas
comme soutien qu'elle un précédent vous
prenez un pull française courait après
madame merkel le moteur franco allemand
c'est d'ailleurs comme je l'espère dans
de la majorité futur des vraies
discussions par forcément les mêmes
positions de départ des compromis et là
on voit aussi compris des rapports de
force qui évolue moi j'ai vu et écouté
le chancelier autrichien qui a n'est pas
changer la vie mais qui a évolué en
renforçant la position du chef d'état
français c'est positif avec des italia
avec les espagnols on voit qu'il ya là
un mouvement ça sur le fond qui fait que
le rapport de force est en train de
s'inverser de falun positif pour la
relance sur des investissements qui
comprit seront très écolo à ces
transports collectifs se serait
l'énergie renouvelable c'est le sont les
bâtiments écolo et c'est très important
que les écologistes abstraction de
nouvelles autoroutes y en a déjà
beaucoup dans le succès venait manger à
paris aussi bien l'europe plus intégrée
et plus écologique vous comprenez qu'on
est donc soutenir ce gouvernement vous
avez utilisé tout à l'heure jean vincent
placé c'est l'ambition vous la
revendiquer collectivement bien sûr mais
également que personnellement perrine
tarneaud arrive juste après ce retour
sur l'épisode de la formation du goulet
aimant qui vous a amené chose rare en
politique à faire un mea culpa être
ambitieux c'est bien mais parfois faut
pas trop la fiche et à mme tran huy il a
suivi françois hollande comme son ombre
mais ça n'a pas suffi le voilà dans le
champ de tous les objectifs le soir du 6
mai aux côtés de l'état major socialiste
même stratégie dans les jours qui ont
précédé et suivi la victoire de françois
hollande
jean vincent placé si vous voyez déjà
nous voulons apporter tout à la fois de
la cuy tout à la fois de la diversité
l'apport des écologistes dans un
gouvernement aux côtés de françois
hollande c'est évidemment plus
d'écologie plus vite et plus loin se
jeter à l'omniprésent jean vincent placé
a donc clamé haut et fort son espoir
ministériel et cette disponibilité ses
ambitions s'inscrivait dans le sillage
de l'accord entre les écologistes et le
ps
pour dominique voynet il faut dire que
les voix écologistes ont compté une
victoire présidentielle bien réel mais
en même temps qui n'est pas si large
qu'on l'avait imaginé avec un résultat
des écologistes qui leur permet
finalement de peser mais la
surmédiatisation des ambitions ce n'est
jamais bon résultat le 16 mai les
espoirs du sénateur écologiste ont été
sévèrement douché pas de jean vincent
placé sur la photo de famille finale
les écologistes ont dû se contenter de
deux postes et à la gauche de la gauche
cela conforte certains dans leur
stratégie
je crois que les écologistes ont joué un
rôle très important de défricheur quand
il était une force autonome qui allait
sur ces couleurs qui qui portait très
fort sa singularité et c'est comme ça
que leur voix à porter très loin elle a
moins porté quand ils ont préféré en
rabattre un peu pour limer les aspérités
et se rendre plus compatible avec un
accord avec le parti socialiste
et même si accord il ya beaucoup
d'écologistes se passe bien devant jean
vincent placé au gouvernement vilipendé
par daniel cohn bendit jugée grotesque
par josé bové dessinateur a lui même
fini par admettre sa faute
voulez-vous devenir ministre non mais je
vais vous dire je suis très content vous
mes invités parce que je veux dire leur
ras-le-bol absolue que j'ai de cette
question d'accords al arabia qui compris
je vais vous dire aussi on peut faire un
peu de
la coule pas bref si la chasse aux
marocains de jean vincent placé avait
été fructueuse
ça aurait fait grincer bien des dents
dans son camp mais c'est là ont vécu en
arranger d'autre j'aurais bien aimé que
ce soit placé soit ministre pour une
seule raison c'est qu'il aurait libéré
une place de sénateur pour un camarade
front de gauche en essonne bref jean
vincent placé prévenu qui part à la
chasse perd sa place à la perrine
tarneaud nous a rejoint dans solar
perrine alors vos questions personnelles
j'imagine avec orange est évident c'est
que la réplication tvtrip on va ya
beaucoup de questions justement autour
du fait que vous n'êtes pas au
gouvernement notamment une question de
livres qu'ils demandent
après tout le mal que vous êtes donné on
vient de le voir encore dans le
reportage
pas trop déçu non jeu est franchement
un plus franc et sincère de dire qu' on
est ambitieux et qu'on veut être dans
l'exécutif
moi j'étais à la région de lefranc
président de gros je suis devenu
vice-président transports j'ai fait ça
avec beaucoup de passion et
d'enthousiasmé
quelque part et c'est ce qui nous
différencie d'une part de certains
partis politiques moi je suis pas
révolutionnaire je suis réformiste est
également cela nous différencie de ceux
qui sont dans les syndicats
autisme qui sont dans les associations
qui ont choisi un autre mode
d'engagement et d'utilité pour la
société et bien moi je souhaite exercer
des responsabilités pour changer les
choses je préfère les propositions de
politiques publiques
après que dans le monde français
particulièrement on soit assez je dis
pas hypocrite mais soucieux vraiment de
dire que voilà moi c'est où évidemment
l'engagement de fond les idées l'intérêt
général bien sûr bien sûr mais risqué
mais je pense que je suis capable
d'exercer la sensibilité tout simplement
après c'est à l'appréciation du
président la république et du chef du
gouvernement et et dont je ne suis pas
déçu parce que les choses sont très bien
comme cela et en plus je vais vous dire
je pense que avec c'est la qualité de ce
gouvernement
eh bien il n'y a pas du tout d'amertume
et de déception à voix pour quelqu'un
comme moi ce que je trouve que les gens
qui y sont sont vraiment très bien parce
qu'on va de l'amertume au sein du groupe
socialiste au sénat parce que il voulait
être un peu nombreux on le sait thierry
repentin qui nous a déclaré il ya deux
jours que le sénat n'avait pas assez de
représentants au sein du gouvernement
puisque nicole bricq un oui mais ça je
les dis je pense que là le gouvernement
est équilibrée y arrêter son du front de
gauche
le déséquilibré même après des
législatives qui redonnerait à une autre
situation de rapport de force je pense
pas que ce soit très n'avions pas
candidat pour le gouvernement
non mais c'est pas un point d'être
candidat ou pas je voulais je répète
toujours la même chose pour exercer des
responsabilités et je continuerai tout à
la fois parler d'écologie à développer
le mouvement écologiste et j'ai
l'impression quand même qu'ils
développent faire en sorte que deux
groupes
ici au sénat travaille bien qu'il y ait
enfin un groupe à l'assemblée que à
terme il plus de responsabilités aux
prochaines élections notre audience
augmente au pouvoir moi je suis là
dessus d'une indéfectible persévérance
en tout cas c'est un échec de la méthode
de jean vincent placé c'est à dire
établir d'entrée un rapport de force
pour arriver
mais je vous remercie de france et qu'il
ya une méthode mais ce service a fait
vingt ans une vie politique est très
clairement j'ai beaucoup plus perdu deux
scrutins que je devais gagner mais tout
simplement parce que je crois que les
idées et tout à la fois de la gauche est
tout à la fois excités des écologistes
ne sont pas majoritaires dans le pays
elles sont pas toujours faciles à
expliquer dans un monde où
l'individualité de plus en plus forts ou
les côtés consumériste aussi il ya
aujourd'hui une difficulté à apprécier
l'engagement politique l'engagement
collectif à faire des choses pour les
autres et je considère qu effectivement
lorsqu'on parle de faire des efforts
qu'on parle de payer des impôts qu'on
parle de réguler c'est pas forcément des
des propositions qui sont majoritaires à
la tuerie cité de s'imposer
continuellement je pense que y compris
d'avoir une soeur certaine audience
médiatique ça aide à parler d'écologie
davantage encore mais vous assumez ce
côté vraiment axé sur le rapport de
force dans vos relations avec les autres
notamment dans le domaine politique
évidemment non mais en revanche
la réalité c'est pas seulement sur le
rapport de force mais la réalité et les
deux se complaisent dans dans la société
tout simplement c'est à dire que moi je
vois nos amis socialistes ils sont de
gauche donc je préfère évidemment
travail et d'ailleurs je ne travaille
qu'avec la gauche dans notre pays et
heureusement
après je constate qu'ils sont plus
productives et ce que nous on a les
dossiers de le père qui nous prive on a
les dossiers de notre dame des landes et
j'ai l'impression que plus on convainc
de citoyennes et citoyens de la
pertinence de nos idées écologiques et
plus on peut peser pour faire en sorte
que justement on puisse sortir nucléaire
à un jour et je suis persuadé que si
depuis deux trois ans nous n'avions pas
plus si nous n'avions pas moins parler
d'écologie programme de françois
hollande ne serait pas arrivé à sa
proposition de compromis sur les 75 %
50% d'énergie de production
d'électricité par énergie nucléaire donc
voilà c'est très important d'avoir une
audience qui s'accroît donc vous pouvez
appeler ça du rapport de force mais on a
posé des questions sur la stratégie
globale
perrine vous interroger sur la méthode
une place et on se dit qu'ils n'ont non
j'ai pas surpris de méthodes passées n'y
a pas eu envie de deux classes et non
non non alors vous en savez plus que moi
en tout cas vous détonner un peu dans le
milieu écologiste et plus de dix ans
après votre votre adhésion vert on se
demande pourquoi vous avez choisi ce
parti eh bien on n'est pas exactement le
profil
pourquoi oui c'est un peu ça passe par
le look et c'est à dire que quand on est
en costume et avec une cravate a donc
condamné soit journalistes
celle d'entreprises soient de droite
c'est quand même bien peu de
journalistes cologie c'est de venir en
arrière je conviens mais plus moi en
plus j'étais j'ai commencé ma carrière
professionnelle comme moniteur financier
donc j'ai peut-être garder ça comme ça
que j'ai plutôt je suis plutôt issu
d'une famille bon jeu mon père la page
de droite disent on voit la
traditionnelle ça c'est bien et très tôt
schussler ma famille être un homme de
gauche un g j'ai voté à gauche tout de
suite
pour françois mitterrand 1988 à la
première élection et parce que je serai
exemple non non pas du tout c'est bien
ce qu'on me pose toujours cette question
là bonjour on attend donc les tuer parce
que j'ai beaucoup réfléchi quand j'étais
adolescent déjà je me suis beaucoup
intéressé à l'histoire de notre pays ou
à la politique à l'engagement et j'ai
une idée comme ça parce que j'ai un
parcours particulier parce que je j'ai
été adoptée venue de corée et j'étais
dans un orphelinat et j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir une éducation dans un milieu
aisé
culturellement et même financièrement et
je me suis dit alors je dis pas que
c'est peut-être un peu caricatural je
veux pas être trop binaire maintenant
mais je me suis dit si on donne des
facilités d'éducation est quelqu'un qui
vient y compris de très très loin
eh bien il ya une possibilité d'en faire
un citoyen convenable voilà et je me
suis dit ça c'est peut-être une valeur
de gauche mais l'éducation la culture la
progression sociale et donc laisser
assez naturellement je me suis tourné
vers la gauche et je vous le dis très
clairement au départ moi je ne suis ni
n'est évidemment ni même été éduqué dans
l'écologie plutôt dans le productivisme
d'ailleurs ma famille et j'ai eu la
chance de rencontrer un michel crépeau
député maire de la rochelle avec lequel
j'ai travaillé comme assistant
parlementaire radical de gauche mais
radicalement syndicalement écolo et mr
écolo il avait déjà effet les vélib des
76 et cette préoccupation d'écologie
urbaine gelé acquise dans le cas de mon
activité professionnelle
et puis la conviction écolo et s'est
construite aussi grâce à la chance comme
souvent de faire des rencontres moi les
miennes c'est en été noël mamère guy
hascouët temps ajouté
dans la majorité sous jospin au
gouvernement
et qui ont fait comprendre que la
question tout à la fois de la planète
des ressources naturelles de la
production était qui sont essentiels
pour la régulation à gauche
et voilà vous voyez comment je suis
devenu écologiste mais finalement mais
que j'ai gardé le costume cravate
peut-être que paradoxalement c'est cette
singularité qui vous a permis une
ascension assez rapide au sein des verts
bon faudrait leur demander mais est
ailleurs et je le dis parce que j'ai
toujours de l'amertume de cela peut-être
derrière est de ma faute mais j'ai la
conviction et de gauche comme je viens
de le dire et écologique et européennes
et républicaine profonde gfc convictions
très fortement ancrée et peut-être y
compris effectivement mon style fait que
on voit plutôt que l'extérieur ou là
comme où le rapport de forces et saab
retient voilà voilà voilà alors que pas
mal d'ennemis au final alors qu'au final
mes proches
alors que mais alors je m'accroche alors
que mes proches ça que j'espère de coton
voilà vous assumer le fait de vous faire
des ennemis
d'emblée non non mais ça ne veut pas je
suis pas sur quoi cette heure-là c'est
bien de faire une psychanalyse que j'ai
jamais fait mais c'est vrai que quand on
est darif comme moi sept en tout petit
et un peu frêle ce qui veut tout à fait
le cas
et sans parler un mot de français il
faut s'affirmer et je sais que quand on
était à 70 comme ça au même collège est
toujours dumas firme et voilà j'ai
toujours dû y compris me fixer des
objectifs dans ma tête pour progresser
et peut-être que maintenant que je suis
plutôt installés que y compris je suis
très heureux dans ma vie personnelle
eh bien eh bien eh bien ils doivent
peut-être y avoir un petit côté plus
sage mao disait
grand homme doit au faîte de sa
puissance garder à 40 enfants donc je ne
suis pas au fait de la puissance mais
j'ai monté un enfant à une dernière
question qui ne vous concerne pas jean
vincent placé est ce que vous comprenez
la tentation de bizerte de bertrand
delanoë paris qui s'y réfugient chez lui
dans sa maison
le ministre comme d'autres alors
je connaissais avant celle de venise qui
était celle là juppé non pour moi c'est
ceci m'a aussi pas si c'est bien ou pas
bien mais il n'est pas rentré au
gouvernement
non mais ça j'en sais rien déjà et puis
ils n'avaient pas boudé une heure et pas
plus innommables
mais même pas non pas qu'il faut il faut
savoir ce délai chose passer à autre
chose et puis continuer ce que je fais
développer l'écologie et il ya du boulot
merci jean vincent placé merci perrine
merci bonsoir à tous et à bientôt donc
pour un prochain numéro deux
transporteurs mais ce sera mardi bien
sûr à 18h pour soir